albert einstein gar ihr geburtshelfer
wir fragen nach
sie gilt bis heute als die wichtigste
entdeckung der neuzeit die einsteinsche
relativitätstheorie erstmals 1905
formulierte aber zehn jahre später als
allgemeine relativitätstheorie die welt
einstein war damals 36 in dieselbe zeit
fallen drei andere nennenswerte
ereignisse und zwar in der kunst
es entstehen das schwarze quadrat von
malewitsch
die chance abstraktion einer frau die
treppe hinunter steigend und picassos
kubismus alles kunstwerke die fixe
vorstellungen von raum und zeit in frage
stellen
der kunsthistoriker christoph wagner
sieht einen zusammenhang zwischen
moderner physik und der kunst avantgarde
diese erschütterung auf eine ganz
radikale weise sozusagen hinter
schritten wird dass das sichtbare von
den naturwissenschaften von der physik
im prinzip aufgelöst wird
das hat sicher natürlich künstler
ermutigt selbst auch in ihren
künstlerischen antworten radikaler sich
zu positionieren
doch was genau an dieser gleichung
interessiert die kunst
nehmen wir das beispiel zweier licht
uhren die zeit die das licht zwischen
den begrenzungen benötigt bestimmt den
takt der uhr befinden sie sich an ort
sind sie im absoluten gleichtakt bewegt
sich eine der beiden uhren muss das
licht einen längeren weg zurücklegen und
vergeht langsamer das heißt die zeit
vergeht für diese und damit für alle
bewegten körper langsamer raum zeit und
lichtgeschwindigkeit hängen voneinander
ab
für die kunst könnte das heißen mag
picasso eine figur in bewegung dann
nimmt er sie in verschiedenen positionen
gleichzeitig war wie hier im bild der
tumor cells avignon dass eine frau
gleichzeitig von hinten und von vorne
darstellt
ist kubismus die relativität des raumes
auf die leinwand gepackt
wir dürfen uns picasa wirklich nicht als
ein verkopften intellektuellen künstler
vorstellen der jetzt in einer
physikalischen theorie nach blätter wie
die neue malerei aussehen soll
und doch findet sich einsteins neues
weltbild auch bei paul klee in klees
konzept des fließenden raumes ist der
raum beweglich und die objekte verlieren
ihre stabile form von klee beeinflusst
haben auch die bauhaus architekten
diesen gedanken aufgenommen in der idee
einer fließenden architektur die kunst
interpretiert das neue physikalische
weltbild ziemlich frei das schöne am
künstlertum ist selbst missverständnisse
führen in der kunst zu sehr produktiven
ergebnissen
damit will ich nicht sagen das klingt
ein stein missverstanden hätte sondern
ich will sagen die hat einstein und
seiner relativitätstheorie wahrgenommen
in einem ganz breiten feld von
anregungen die ihn fasziniert haben dass
sich die zeit verändert je nach
geschwindigkeit im raum inspiriert auch
heute noch die kunst wie diese uhr die
unterschiedliche tempi anzeigen kann
die künstlerin alicja kwade appliziert
relativitätstheorie auf unseren alltag
ich zeige eigentlich das was man drin
man dreht sich einmal um es ist sechs
uhr morgens
es ist ein doch ein finde ich ein sehr
großes hang beweis dafür dass da
durchaus was wahres dran ist und es ist
immer auch somit ein bisschen mit mit
natürlich mit einem schmunzeln für mir
auch irgendwie gedacht
in ihrer ausstellung im haus am waldsee
in berlin spielt quade mit einem ganzen
repertoire an einsteins theorien an ein
wurmloch nur zu einem röhrensystem dass
alle räume durchdringt
objekte fallen aus dem normalen raum
zeitraster und wenn man sich hier
spiegelt soll klar werden raum ohne zeit
ist nicht möglich selber der man altert
der raum in dem man sich befindet der
gekrümmt in dieser scheibe zu sehen ist
und das ist ja eigentlich genau das ist
ganz einfach eine abstrakte formen
bestimmt die welt und die kunst versucht
sie erlebbar zu machen